[Music]
welcome back to peacefulness and
delighted to be joined now by deepak
chopra deepak welcome to piers morgan
understands that i need to start an
apology because i'm told the one thing
you don't like being called is a guru so
me repeatedly calling you the guru of
all gurus probably was not the best way
to introduce you earlier how do you like
to be
described
so pierce let me ask you a question
can you spell guru for me
g-u-r-u
that's it g you are you the only guru
is your own self
everything else
everything else is an impersonation
so
how do you best describe yourself d-pap
i'm still trying to decide what i'll do
when i grow up
i think
any any description you have of yourself
is limiting
yeah i know i know what you mean the
reason i wanted to get you on was
because i just get a feeling a lot of
people think the world's gone completely
crazy you know we've had a global
pandemic a war in europe uh surging
inflation possibly a recession culture
wars erupting all over the place council
culture and so on
can you put it into some kind of
historical perspective are things any
better or worse now than they've been
before and if the world is going a bit
crackers what's the best advice for
dealing with it
so very well stated if you do not
believe that the world is going insane
then you're declaring your own insanity
what do you call a world that is
sleepwalking to extinction right now
with climate change
with social and economic injustice
with
mass migrations
with pandemics
with
mechanized ways of killing each other
cyber warfare terrorism
the immense fear sympathetic overdrive
sleepwalking to extinction is insanity
so we are definitely at a crossroads
where we need a new story
for our well-being a new story for
humanity and a new story for this planet
otherwise
we are doomed we are sleepwalking as i
said to extinction if insects
disappeared from this planet in five
years all life on this planet would
cease if humans disappeared from this
planet in five years all life on this
planet would flourish we would return to
the state of innocence the state of
grace and the garden of eden now
metaphorically speaking what i'm saying
is not just a metaphor it's literal this
world right now
does not realize that what we call the
average is the
psychopathology of the insane divided
tribal conditioned mind with modern
capacities
you're saying are things any different
well in a way they aren't you know i
mean i spoke to my band i spoke to my
parents long time ago they spoke of the
holocaust the second world war the
atomic bomb my grandfather spoke about
the first world war the pandemic
but what we have today appears is modern
capacities for mechanized extinction and
death and tribal medieval minds the
combination doesn't work we also have a
another threat and i want to preface
this uh by playing a clip i did i did
the last television interview with
professor stephen hawking before he died
it was a remarkable day incredible
experience in my life i have to say but
i did put to him a specific question
about what is the biggest threat to
civilization here was his response
there is a greater danger from
artificial intelligence if we allow it
to become self-designing for then it can
improve itself rapidly and we may lose
control
you know i was reminded of that today
with this extraordinary story of the
google engineer who claims that uh an
artificial intelligence bot that they do
a language model for dialogue
applications had turned sentient was
beginning to express emotions and
feelings and responses of a seven to
eight year old
human child now google have denied it
but i was cognizant as i heard read the
story about what professor hawking had
warned me about which is the threat from
artificial intelligence if it ever does
self-design
well i am a fan of artificial
intelligence in fact i have a replica of
mine called
digitaldeepak.ai ai you can check him
out on the internet and he knows more
about
everything than i do he's read my 95
books and
he can be an excellent coach for
well-being etc on the google statement
or the google news it's absolutely
ridiculous absolutely
a joke does the ai have anxiety about
death that the exa ai have sex does the
ai feel hunger or thirst does the ai
have existential dilemmas the ai is just
an algorithm what professor hawking said
is true though unless we have ethical
ethical
editors editing of ai it could turn to
be dangerous but i don't think it could
ever be sentient and already there's a
move in the ai world called ethical ai
where you build in safeguards against ai
taking over or destroying humanity and
you use ai for things that we don't you
know right now for example the legal
system is going to be obsolete because
of ai the regular contracts diagnosis
precision diagnosis
deep learning remote surgery these are
all happening because of air we could
relegate these things to ai so that we
can tap into our consciousness for
insight intuition creativity higher
consciousness and create a critical mass
for a more peaceful just sustainable
healthier and joyful world and ai has a
role
provided we are also aware of its
possible dangers there's no technology
which comes without danger pierce
fascinating uh deep let me ask you about
another thing which has been bothering
me all these mass shootings we've been
seeing in america
two of the common themes around it are
not just guns obviously
which are the weapons used but in my
view something else is going on here
which is a combination of the sensory
overload that young people are now
getting just generally you know both the
shooter in the avalde texas school mass
shooting and the and the sandy hook
shooter were both addicted to call of
duty the war game for example and
hollywood stars today have all signed a
petition to try and reduce the amount of
glamorizing of gun violence in movies
and i spoke to dr phil
a few couple of years ago and he said
the difference between today were young
people when he was young was that the
amount of of bad stuff that young people
see
now through social media through clips
that do the rounds of their friends and
so on is relentless
and is damaging to people what do you
think about
well there are many issues first of all
america particularly has a romantic
relationship
with guns and with violence
and so does hollywood have a romantic
relationship it doesn't matter
we're going into the different galaxies
but we're still talking about star wars
everything is about a war violence is
part of our culture and our romance with
violence is what makes money for
hollywood and for entertainment and it's
the ultimate hypocrisy the other thing
is americans like to talk about the
second amendment or you know the right
to carry guns but in the moment they'll
strip women of their rights for their
reproductive rights so it's total
hypocrisy and it's driven by money and
unless we address
the free say you can a teenager cannot
buy cigarettes or alcohol or pornography
but can go to a 7-eleven or some walmart
or whatever
you know a gun store
although walmart is changing his
policies and get a gun so this is very
ridiculous what's happening in america
unfortunately the rest of the world
follows america and so between gun
violence the romanticization
of violence in general
war and terrorism as something to be
looked up to and
the
chain of money that drives these with
special interest groups especially in
washington there are for every
every legislator there are 30 healthcare
lobbyists 30 gun lobbies 30 you know
people from the medical industrial
complex so what we call corruption
cronyism influence peddling and gangster
leadership is taking over the world and
we really have to resist that we are at
a crossroads now with new things
emerging like blockchain and
nfts and metaverse where i think we'll
need to take
power away from these people who are
only interested in cronyism corruption
and money peddling and bring democracy
truly uh on a global level
through
information technologies and even ai
you know deepak you always express these
things so eloquently uh far better than
i could you're a great book out
abundance in a path to wealth uh you got
the idea i understand from the bob
marley lyrics some people are so poor
all they have is money which is
brilliant uh deep i've got to leave it
there i could talk to you for hours and
we'd love to get you back again thank
you it's great to talk to you again
thank you very much for joining me thank
you thank you very much pierce